and in this moment
of uncertainty
of continuing fear
and doubt about the future
i have
one
message
for you today
ukraine will win
will
would have to be reformed outside
ukraine maybe even in
poland or
or in london perhaps and i
refused to believe it
and today
you have proved them completely wrong
every one of those military experts who
said that ukraine would fall
and you've beaten them back from kiev
you have exploded the myth
of putin's
invincibility
and you've written one of the most
glorious chapters
in military history
and in the life
of your country
the so-called irresistible force of
putin's war machine has broken
on the immovable object
of ukrainian patriotism
and love
of country
this
is ukraine's finest hour
that will be remembered
and recounted
for generations to come
your children and your grandchildren
will say that ukrainians taught the
world
that the brute force of an aggressor
counts for nothing against the moral
force of the people determined to be
free
as you turn the russian army back from
the gates of kiev you not only
accomplished one of the greatest feats
of arms of the 20th century 21st century
you achieved something
deeper and perhaps equally significant
you exposed the historic folly
that putin
has made
i can announce today from the uk
government
a new package of support
totaling 300 million pounds including
radars
to pinpoint the artillery
bombarding your cities
heavy lift drones to supply your forces
and thousands of night vision devices
we will carry on supplying ukraine
alongside your other friends with
weapons funding and humanitarian aid
until we have achieved our long-term
goal
which must be
[Applause]
the
[Applause]
johnson
foreign